it takes Cornelius Diekman 6.58 seconds
to crack the cube just one second more
than the world record the Berliner is a
three-time German speed cubing champion
he liked it even buffets anthem and
people who have a Rubik's Cube for the
first time tend to use their whole hand
and move it quite roughly and I don't
even turn it but I would take longer
than ten seconds you can compare it with
someone who sits a piano keyboard for
the first time we would also touch each
note with his index finger but a pianist
uses all ten fingers and that's what I
do I use all ten fingers on the cube
when so much doesn't it the viola off
it's been it's all the same thing a plus
even often both it
that's hogging the number of possible
permutations a smooth 43 quintillion the
aim of the game is to get every one of
the six sides covered in one single
color the Rubik's Cube is probably the
best-selling brain teaser of all time
it's famous worldwide but not everyone
knows that it was invented in Hungary
oh I think the oriental they they are
very smart so Chinese new Chinese people
maybe cube that was made by a Hungarian
man Ruby and he designed this and it
became very famous all over the world
the magic cube as it was originally
called was invented at the Hungarian
University of Arts and Design in
Budapest
now the moholy-nagy University of Arts
and Design anaerobic a sculptor and
architecture professor there first
presented his cube in 1974 but it took
six years for it to become a
commercially available toy it was
initially a teaching tool I think
teaching was one of the reason behind a
cube it's because I I was searching
interesting example of three-dimensional
structures and how we can illustrate the
nature of dimensions the genius was
conjuring up the hidden mechanism that
connected the 26th cubelets Rubik
patented his invention in 1975 in 1980 a
u.s. toy firm obtained the license to
release it worldwide and renamed it
after its maker the 1980 was the
interaction the International action of
the cube and it's practically advance in
a year the cube became a huge craze and
the company sold about 100 million in
three years and in the real world there
are speed cubing championships held
every four years to find the swiftest
finger Smith's on the planet escape dr.
Hansen vet there are tournaments all
over the world a lot in Germany but also
in the US and in Asia you always meet
new people with similar interests I
think that if I weren't up against the
clock and myself I wouldn't do this with
so much passion it's alive schuftis
muscles
the cube spawned a whole host of
imitations the pyraminx was invented
independently of the cube boom Rubik's
magic was another puzzle based on tiles
but the Masters now working on a
different project I'd like to finish my
last one that's the exhibition but is
started close to five years ago and it
will travel about six six seven years
and after circling the globe beginning
in the US it will come to Budapest which
is where being square actually first
became cool 40 years ago